حسن
جبهه على مسافه 900 كم جبهه بريه تقريبا
ثابته باستثناء بخموت او حتى بكبيانسك
الجيش الروسي يعد لهجوم مضاد اليوم
الانتقال الى مرحله ثانيه هي بحريه بريه
تستهدف اهم منطقه في العمق الروسي هي شبه
جزيره
القرمسكي مهمه لماذا اذا اخذنا التفجير
بجسر كرش كرش على نفس المسار الطريق
السريع ام 17 كيلو
وهي عقده اساسيه مهمه منها يبدا الاتجاه
باتجاه
وهنا دمر سابقا او استهدف جسر شنهار او
الى ارميانسك باتجاه خرسون فاذا نحن نتحدث
عن عقد طرق اهداف استراتيجيه مهمه والهدف
منها دائما هو حرمان او منع الجيش الروسي
من اللوجستيه التي يعتمد عليها والتي
يستهلك الكثير فيها خاصه في الذخيره عميد
الياس حنا في موضوع هذا التصعيد في شبه
جزيره القرم على وجه التحديد لماذا لا
ياتي التبني الاوكراني سريعا وواضحا بهذا
الخصوص
يعتبر يعني هذه من المقاربه النكران او
الدينايل كما يقال لانه اليوم
هناك حريق من نفذه هل هي مسيره هذا امر
مستبعد المنطقه بعيده هل هي عمليه خاصه
ايضا هل هي من ضمن ما يسمى بالمقاومه
الداخليه خاصه من فصائل من التتار تعارض
الوجود الروسي في القرن هذا هذا النكران
هذا الغموض في المقاربه يجعل الروس يفكرون
اكثر ويبدون قلقين في اي مكان من هنا
تسكير جسر قرش اليوم لمنع الحريق واخلاق
ما يقارب الالفين وحتى عندما استهدف جسر
كارش منذ يومين مريم بدات العجقه السيارات
كما يقال على الطرق الداخليه في اوكرانيا
اما 14 من ماريوبول الى ميليتو بول الى
خرسون فاذا انت تضعين الكثير من الفوضى
على منظومه اصبحت
تقريبا فوضويه بسبب التغيير في القيادات
توقيف القيادات تشكيل القيادات العسكريه
بعد تمرد بريكوجين
الجانب الروسي حتى الان لم يحسم لا من
المسؤول عن هذا الحريق ولا حتى سبب الحريق
لكن هي قاعده جويه فيها الكثير من الذقائر
تنفجر الذقائر وهي يفترض عمليا انها محميه
بصواريخ ومضادات وغير ذلك الوصول اليها
بهذا الشكل باي وسيله كانت ماذا يعني
النشوب حريق بهذا الشكل ممتد الى يوم غد
على ما يتوقع الخبراء الروس
حسن تعودنا خلال هذه الحرب سنه واربعه او
خمسه اشهر ان الامن العماني للوحدات
الروسيه لم يكن كما يجب والدليل على ذلك
هو مقتل العديد من القيادات العسكريه
اخرها في برديانسك باستهداف ستورم شادو
لقاعده جويه فيها
طوافات تساعد على منع الهجوم الاوكراني في
ايضا حتى شبه حتى جسر قرش تم استهدافه في
اكتوبر الماضي وهو مهم جدا جدا من اهم من
اهم المناطق والاهداف الاستراتيجيه
للروسيه حتى الان لم يستطع الروسي والامن
الروسي ان يؤمن هذا الجسر والدليل على ذلك
انها وجدت اثنين هناك العديد من هذه
الاماكن لم تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار فاذا الامن
العماني للوحدات المنتشره ليست بهذا بهذه
الدقه مع العلم حسن انه ليس هناك من امن
مطلق في حرب مفتوحه وفي حرب تقريبا فوضويه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد الياس
حنا شكرا جزيلا لك حدثتنا من بيروت